my name is Bethany McLain and I've
written the inaugural book for Columbia
global reports it's called
shaky ground the strange saga of the
u.s. mortgage giants and it's about
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac I think the
notion that Fannie and Freddie are a
global concern is really ironic on the
surface and it almost sounds far-fetched
because homes are the most domestic
asset there is right they are literally
rooted to the ground rooted to our soil
but yet over the decades thanks in large
part to Fannie and Freddie a great
percentage of the American homeownership
market has actually come to be financed
through foreign investors but as a
result foreign investors own a lot of
the securities issued by Fannie and
Freddie which makes their health their
solvency of primary concern not just to
American political interest but to
global political interests in the world
today given various changes including
the impact of the internet on the
business model of journalism there has
been notably and significantly a decline
in in-depth journalism on global issues
so I have long felt that a university
should take on to some extent this
mission we have a subject which is
globalization we're never going to
publish a book saying here's what
globalization is folks
so each book is a specific part of it
and we strive for diversity of authorial
voices and styles diversity of geography
and diversity of subject matter so the
way this book happened was I took
Bethany who's a wonderful reporter an
old friend out to lunch and said what
hasn't been fixed yet from the financial
crisis you know we had General Motors
who was bankrupt and now it's out of
bankruptcy the banks were you know in
tarp and now tarp is over what what
hasn't been done and she said the
biggest unresolved problem from the
financial crisis is Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac the two government connected
entities in Washington that that sort of
guarantee and underlie the home mortgage
mark
the central issue of the book is
something that most people don't
actually know somebody asked me today
well what happened to Fannie and Freddie
after the government took them over well
the answer is they're still owned by the
government they're in this state called
conservatorship which was supposed to be
temporary after the financial crisis and
there they said in fact because most
mortgages made in this country are now
purchased by Fannie and Freddie you
could view the entire mortgage market in
this country as being as being
government backed and I think that's
something most people don't understand
and that that notion that we have this
this thing called housing that was at
the epicenter of the financial crisis
and the two entities that do housing are
still totally unresolved and in this
supposedly temporary state they were put
into after after the crisis I think is
astounding